[Музика]
Я сам це пережив у Варшаві
міська залізниця, як молодий поляк
так би мовити, образив україну і
що такі голоси лунають на повну гучність
зараз, на жаль, чути частіше
можливо, цей фільм настільки важливий
це для майбутнього і для них
опрацювання важкої історії
цей фільм має сьогодення
атмосфера дещо складніша і
зробив трохи більш напруженим
безумовно, залишаються стратегічними для Польщі
інтереси, а також нижче
попередні уряди були, але ви повинні
з іншого боку, скажімо, країна в ЄС
його зайві запаси зброї
передали україні, що було
Литва Польща не має нічого в напрямку
зроблено
про це зараз багато говорять
що ви можете зробити економічно
інфраструктурна енергетична політика
заздалегідь
про це багато говорять
лібералізація візового режиму в Польщі є
Особливе занепокоєння, що саме коли
Україні незабаром буде дозволено вільний в'їзд
Європейський Союз, що тоді
всі трудові мігранти переїжджають на
на захід і не залишатися в Польщі
тому один розглядає зараз вид
сприяння зеленій картці для україни
запровадити в Польщі
польсько-українські відносини
щойно отримав полірування
член уряду сказав, що ви а
невикористаний потенціал серед
торговими партнерами Польщі є
Україна на 22 місці
стосунки з одного боку
історично обтяжений, з іншого боку
важливе стратегічне партнерство
міграційне партнерство, якщо вам це подобається
хочуть
живе близько мільйона українців
тим часом поляки